you're right now finally there's no
chance to come back absolutely nothing
to be done
i mean just look at the poor bishop
that's sitting there on the h2 square
i mean it might as well be a pawn
this move is a killer you're threatening
to you know just take the night and
check mate yeah you're right your anchor
and uh you're also not just the exchange
out you're you're pawn up now as well so
i mean any ending is
just trivial
um
the king comes out
where's the killer blinders couple here
surely a couple of killer blows i mean
yeah you've got many many winning moves
there you can take a pawn with your bish
with the black bishop uh you can even
just capture the white knight with the
black rook i think that's just a
straightforward win this is the most
simple end result
wow what can i say what's the result
phenomenal right
what a result yeah you said it david
incredible start to the day for hans
niemann the lowest rated player in the
tournament with the black pieces a win
against world number one